DR. DARLENE LIM: OK.
All right.
Well, thanks so
much to everybody
in the room who came
out and everybody
who's online virtually.
I really appreciate
your time in being here.
So I am from NASA,
but my background
is actually as a
field scientist.
And so I've been going
out to really interesting,
kind of weird places
around the world basically
since I was a kid-- since
I was about 17 years old.
And then luckily for me,
managed to kind of dovetail that
into a real adult
job, so to speak.
But I still get to go out into
some really interesting places
that I'm going to be
talking to you about today.
I primarily work
underwater, but I also
have now kind of
expanded my horizons.
I work in deserts.
I work in cold polar regions
on the surface as well.
And we sort of, at NASA, have
used this opportunity where
we are out in these
field environments
doing research as a
mechanism by which
to learn how to do science
in extreme environments.
And the idea is to
take the learning
that we gather from
these environments
and export them in terms
of how we set ourselves up
for success scientifically,
and also in terms of protecting
the people that are out there,
for when we actually go off
Earth into places like the
moon, to asteroids, and to Mars.
So that's going to be sort of
the focus of my talk today.
And one of the main
things that we contend
with when we move beyond
the earth are time delays.
So, you know, I
remember using, whenever
I used to call my grandma,
or even when my boyfriend who
became my husband--
he went to Japan
and taught English in 1995
or something like that--
and speaking to him on
the phone there was always
that hiccup-- that
kind of time delay.
So irritating.
And that's just having
a regular conversation.
When you start to inject
in a known time delay,
moving from let's say lunar
circumstances where you have
a second delay one way,
which is, you know,
two plus seconds return, or if
you're moving to an asteroid
where it's 50 seconds
one way delay,
and then outwards to Mars, where
it could be 10, 15, 20 minutes,
it gets problematic,
especially if you
have humans at the other end who
need to respond to others that
are sitting on Earth and
dealing with information
and trying to get
information back.
So what we do out in
the field is basically
what I'm going to talk to
you about today in terms
of learning how to
contend with those issues
when you have lots of scientists
who are very demanding,
real engineering issues,
and people at the other end
who have to stay alive, and
how do we deal with all that
when we're in the field.
Let me expand this so we
can see the big slides.
So as I mentioned very
quickly in my intro,
the three places
that have come up,
which depending on the
flavor of the month
we are or are not allowed
to speak about in terms
of a destination, but you
will hear in the corridors,
tends to be the moon, Mars,
and the moon of Mars even,
or an asteroid.
These are all the long-term
human exploration targets
that we're interested in.
There are various
reasons why we might
want to go to each of
these different targets.
The moon is close
by, so to speak.
It is somewhere
that we can get to
within a reasonable
amount of time
and come back if there's
some safety issues.
Asteroids have been
a number of reasons
that are listed, whether it's
from the planetary sciences
to maybe economic
reasons that we
may want to go to an asteroid.
One mission that you may
or may not have heard about
is called the Asteroid
Retrieval Mission or ARM,
which is actually capturing
a near-Earth asteroid
and bringing that back
nearby to the moon in one
of the what's called
the Lagrange points.
And then Mars.
Mars has always been on our
kind of, I guess, vision path.
And even outside of NASA.
I mean, you may have read
lots of different books
and have thought
about it yourself
in terms of an interesting
destination to go.
Whether or not it's just to
get there or for the science,
it may be a very
interesting place
to investigate for signs
of past life or present day
life within our solar system.
So those are some of the
regions that we want to get to.
But in all cases-- well, I
can actually click, I think.
In all cases, we are
going to be dealing,
as I mentioned, with varying
degrees of communication
latencies, whether it's
ranging from a lunar surface,
as I mentioned 1.2
seconds is the closest
kind of one-way light time
delay that you would experience,
all the way to if
you were operating
say on the moons of Mars where
you'd get up to 186 seconds
or at an asteroid where it's
50 second one-way delay.
So you multiply that by two,
and you've got difficulties.
And times two that is
just the bare minimum
of what you're dealing
with in terms of the delay
that one would have in making
a decision that's a group team
decision between those
that are out in the field
and those that are actually
sitting back home ensconced
in the safety of Earth.
So what we're doing within
our field programs--
and I'm going to show you
in a couple of slides--
is actually focusing
on understanding
the operational
concepts that we need
to support humans and
robots working in tandem
or working in sort
of a phase way
out in extreme environments.
And so there's a
couple of terms that'll
keep coming up that I wanted
to define early on in the talk.
One of them is Concepts of
Operations or ConOps, which
are defined as these
operational design elements--
how you organize people,
how you actually flow them
through different pathways
when you are doing
different tasks-- as well
as the term capabilities.
So this can be defined as any
functional aspect of a mission,
ranging from
hardware to software.
So we will look at what
are the capabilities that
are required to support
humans and robots working
in these extreme
environments as well as
what are the concepts of
operations-- the ConOps--
that are needed as well.
So there are a
variety of different
what are called analogs
within the NASA family.
They do different things.
They serve different purposes.
And some of them have
really nifty acronyms
such as NEEMO as
Chris mentioned.
But they all kind of
join up to one big loop
of transfer of knowledge.
So NEEMO is actually
conducted-- these
are some images from
the NEEMO test site
out in the Florida Keys.
And this test or this analog
makes use of the Aquarius base.
I don't know if you guys have
heard about this Aquarius is
actually a submerged base.
It's about 60 feet underwater,
and it's out in Florida Keys,
as I mentioned.
And people have used
this over the years
to basically learn about
these aquatic-- the marina
environment by actually being
ensconced in it through the day
and night.
And they will
actually live in there
for like 7, 14 days at a time.
So everyone from offspring
of Jacques Cousteau
to James Cameron to like
real scientists and so forth
have used this
environment over time.
And so NASA uses
it as well in order
to send out their aquanauts into
this micro-gravity environment
so that they can learn about
different sort of hardware
support elements that one would
need when you're out operating
on say the moon or an asteroid.
So that is one really
interesting analog
that I've had the pleasure
of being involved with.
And then another is actually
this thing called Desert Rats.
So this is based in and
around the Flagstaff region
in Arizona.
And the intent here is
to actually sort of use
these larger hardware that
are being built-- things
like this what's called a
Space Exploration Vehicle.
It's an analog to a
pressurized vehicle
that we may want to drive around
on the surface of the moon
or Mars or actually use as a
free flyer into an asteroid.
It will keep your astronauts
nice and safe and cozy
within this pressurized
environment.
And you can drive around
for quite a distance
and then actually have
people exit that vehicle
and go on what's called
extravehicular activities
or EVAs.
So these two test
environments are actually
used as field tests
for the engineers.
And they also do, at the
Johnson Space Center,
a lot of lab experiments--
simulations on whether
that's-- I'll show you a couple
of pictures in a moment--
tying people up and actually
having them on a tether
and mimicking, once again,
this micro-gravity environment
and trying to use
different tools to say,
sample an asteroid.
So all of these are very
engineering focused.
And where we come in with
the Pavilion Lake Research
Project, which is the
topic or the project
that I'm going to be
spending most time on today,
is that we offer a
basis of real science.
And so what that does is
there are different tests that
go on at these three
fields sites that
lead to learning in terms
of what are the best ConOps
and capabilities that the
engineers have identified
to support different
EVA capabilities?
And then they come to
us and they say, OK.
So what happens if
we're doing science?
Do these learnings
actually still hold?
Are they still worth what
we think they're worth?
And so we will go underwater
into Pavilion Lake
and conduct our science and
actually absorb their learning
and test it there.
So that's this kind of nice
little family of NASA analogs
that are still in operation
and working together.
So some of the concepts
that are being tested
at NEEMO, at Desert
Rats previously, as well
as in the lab, are, for example,
this is an asteroid mission
where you have an
asteroid that's actually
in anchored into the asteroid
itself, working along a grid
and examining it, and figuring
out which samples to collect.
Another possible scenario
for going to an asteroid
is where you have this
pressurized vehicle
with an arm at the end.
And this arm is actually
supporting ask an astronaut,
and then free-flying
the astronaut
into a specific site
of interest and then
having them kind of
examine it based on that.
So they will go through, in
these NEEMO and Desert Rats
environments, and test
these different scenarios.
They have like seven,
10 different conditions
that they'll look at at
any one point in time.
They deal with everything
from one person
at a base that's kind
of orbiting or nearby
to an asteroid,
and then two people
going on EVA to, for
example, two SEVs coming
in-- free flyers-- and actually
supporting the EVA that way.
So what's used are metrics.
This is a bit of an eyesore.
I apologize.
These are slides that have
been absorbed for my NASA
presentations where we
love tiny, tiny text.
It's like if you
squint you can see it.
Apparently it's not valid
unless it's tiny and prolific
in terms of text.
But anyways, we will
look at everything
from the simulation
itself and what kind
of quality of simulation
did we actually conduct.
So for example, if we're
connecting a simulation
and, let's say, the
network is down, well
that's a poor simulation.
I mean, we didn't
simulate anything
because everything was broken.
So that's a very
simple anecdote,
but those are the types of
things that will make sure
that we score before we
move on to the other ratings
that we collect.
We look at the acceptability
of the simulation as well
as the capabilities themselves,
and we assess those.
And as we use
those metrics we'll
actually use them
in very set moments
in time during our
simulations themselves.
So we move from the lab, as I
mentioned, out into the field.
You see here there's actually
the free flyer testing
one of those conditions.
And, of course,
this free flyer is
roving with wheels on
the surface of the desert
and connected to an
astronaut right here who's
working under different
types of time constraints.
So they may only have 20 minutes
to be out there or two hours
to be out there depending on the
condition that they're testing.
These are some more images, once
again taking the lessons that
are learned from
Desert Rats where
one great thing about that
environment is that, of course,
if anything goes wrong they're
above-- they're on the land,
you can breathe the air, there's
nothing dangerous about it.
But they will take the
lessons from Desert Rats
and test it
underwater, where you
are dealing with some
real, intrinsic dangers.
And so the kind of fidelity or
the realness of the simulation
increases just that much
more and is that much more
similar to operating in space.
And so in this case, this
is called a Deep Workers
Single Person
Submersible, and there's
a boom off the front
here with an astronaut,
or an aquanaut-- pardon
me-- connected at the end.
And so we'll test
different ConOps once again
under these more
real conditions.
This is an image here
of a lab-based test
that post-NEEMO was
used to actually examine
some of these
collection mechanisms
as well as the idea of being
tethered on an astronaut--
pardon me-- an asteroid.
So what has been found
that we have since
absorbed within the science
program is the following-- that
to summarize really, astronauts
like to be independent.
And so what we've found
is that these types
of modes where you have
people that are actually
on the end of a boom, while
the rate is acceptable--
let me show you what happens
a little later on here--
is that the crew
actually ends up
preferring you know
these types of scenarios
where you have a
couple of people
back in this SEV supporting
a crew member at the end,
whether they're
untethered or tethered.
Folks just-- this
seems to be the most
proficient and
efficient way to work
in terms of
surveying an asteroid
and then actually
having somebody
back within this deep space
kind of connection point
serving as a relay
back to Earth.
And so they went
through and tested
these different scenarios
and then came to us and said,
OK, well, we want to test out
this particular scenario here,
but we want to do it within
a real science environment.
So this is where the Pavilion
Lake Research Project comes in.
So PLRP, as I
mentioned early on,
is a project that's
based in science.
We have been there for 10 years.
We've been really lucky.
We've cycled through
different modes of funding
and managed to create
a long-term program.
And the essence of
it was to examine
something called microbialites.
Microbialites are-- the first
part of the word, microbe,
and then the second part
of the word-- pardon
me-- part of the word,
-ite, infers rock.
So they're rocks that
are built by microbes.
And we have been examining these
rocks-- these microbialites--
within Pavilion Lake because
they are within our Earth's
rock record the earliest
and longest lasting
kind of macro
indications of life.
So you may have heard about
Shark Bay and the stromatolites
there and some of the old
fossilized stromatolites
within, let's say, the Mojave
Desert or in Australia.
So those are rocks
that have been built up
over time by microbes
and show us really strong
evidence that life
has been around
on our planet for over
2.5 billion years, three
billion years, that
sort of time frame.
So when we think about going
to somewhere like Mars,
those are the types
of things that we
may want to look for if we're
looking for past signs of life
are these rock records.
So the cool thing about Pavilion
Lake is that in a modern sense,
microbialites have been found
in very extreme environments,
typically high salinity,
high alkalinity.
But this lake in Canada
is 4 and 1/2 hours
eastbound of Vancouver.
People live by the lake.
It's pH of about 8.3.
People will drink in it.
They'll swim.
They'll water ski in it.
And yet, if you put
your heads under water,
it's like you're going
back through time millions,
billions of years.
You have very, very large
microbialites there.
So that was why we initially
went to Pavilion Lake.
But I've been part of this
project since its inception,
and I have a very
kind of a longstanding
since I was a kid
interest in exploration,
and that's why I went to NASA.
And so we found that, while
we were there operating
underwater, that this was a
fantastic environment by which
to offer that sort of
testing environment
to the other operational
groups at NASA.
And so that's how we've become
part of the analog community.
So this is a lot
of text that I'll
skip through that
basically says what
I've said-- that
we're science driven.
But just to give you a bit
more of an overview for those
who are interested in the
science, this is Pavilion Lake.
It's a lake that's almost
six kilometers long,
and it drops down at its
deepest point to over 200 feet.
It's not a terribly deep
lake, but it's deep enough
that it's challenging for us.
So we've moved through a
bunch of different assets
as was quickly shown
to you in that video
to explore the lake for
the purposes of science.
These are the microbialites
and were pictures of them.
And they range in
size from, you know,
these are maybe the size
of a football all the way
to the deeper sections
of the lake where
we're getting to
30 or 35 meters,
and these are nearly six
feet across and just over
six feet high.
So these have been
growing in this lake
for almost 12,000 years or so.
And nobody really
knows why it is
that this lake is
supporting these structures,
and that's what we've
been there over time.
We certainly know a lot
more about the chemistry
and so forth that
is supporting it.
So we're working
at different levels
in the lake in terms
of the science.
And this is going
to be important
as we go through the talk, so
it's why I wanted to show you
that we're not only working
at these kind of macro scales
where we're trying to
understand the different shapes
and sizes of the
microbialites in the lake
and what they're
associated with,
whether it's weird chemistry
in different parts of the lake,
different types of
topography in the lake,
or what's called
bathymetry, or if there
are different organisms
that are associated
with the surface
of these structures
themselves that are causing
these different shapes
and sizes.
So some of our scientists are
looking at the different layers
down to millimeter,
sub-millimeter scale,
and trying to understand
the carbonate that's
being generated
by these microbes
and whether or not there's
a signature of life that's
being left behind and
whether we can associate
that with different organisms.
So all of that plays
back into astrobiology,
but it's challenging,
as I mentioned,
the lake drops down
to over 200 feet.
It's pretty long.
And when we first got there
in '04, we only thought that
the microbialites were in one
very small section of the lake.
So we started just kind of
investigating a little bit
around where we were
initially working in,
discovered that, in fact,
although there was a paper that
first came out in 2000
that described that very
small swath, we discovered that
there were microbialites all
the way down to the
200 foot depth, which
is just as the light
starts to peter out.
And that was important
to us because we
figured that the
microbialites petered out
further up around 80 to
90 feet, because that's
where the incoming light
really started to diminish.
But in fact, there are
microbialites that are actively
growing even at the kind of
deepest depths of the lake.
So suddenly what that
did for a science is it
made it very interesting
but very difficult
for us to really get
at the knowledge who
wanted to get at just using
divers or just using robots.
So we managed to kind of work
with three different assets--
the autonomous
underwater vehicles,
these deep workers,
and then scuba divers.
And we move through
different phases
of the program with
these different assets.
So the submersibles allowed
us to put scientists-- yes.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: You had
intellectual resolution.
DR. DARLENE LIM: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is?
DR. DARLENE LIM: Thanks
for asking the question.
So the question
for those who are
out there is what
on this slide does
real time intellectual
resolution mean?
It's totally made
up, but what it is
is something that we were
interested in examining
in terms of the
return to our science.
So when you look at
a diver, the diver
can only stay under
water at-- the altitude
of this lake is at 2,800 feet.
It's very cold-- four
degrees Celsius-- for maybe
like 20 to 40 minutes at best.
But they can get in real nice
and close with their subject.
And they are usually very highly
trained in terms of the science
and so forth.
So there are
intellectual resolution
in terms of their ability to
think about what they're seeing
and absorb it and consider
maybe new hypotheses or test
hypotheses in real time
was medium to high.
Now when we think about getting
down to depths of 200 feet,
we can't actually put
divers breathing air down
at that level
without putting them
through decompression dives.
And so what we decided to do
is move into this deep worker
phase of the
program where we put
the scientists into
this environment here.
So it's actually, in terms of
the work that we were doing,
which was mapping,
and our ability
to interact with our
environment very intimately,
once again this, in
a real time basis,
it was sort of a medium
to high rating as well.
The AUV, which was--
you know, it's a robot.
You just program
it, and it goes out
and it collects data for
you in terms of imaging
or [INAUDIBLE] sonar,
whatever you want.
We were actually expecting
it to be exactly the tool
that we needed and
that we didn't actually
have to put people underwater.
But we found it very limited
in terms of what it returned.
This doesn't show up very
well on the screen here,
but we got black and
white images back
of high definition
black and white images.
But it still didn't
give us the opportunity
to understand the morphology
or the shapes and sizes
as they pertained to
different regions in the lake
and get to the
science we wanted to.
So this was part of our
justification, part of our real
thought process, to really take
ourselves to whether or not
we should be actually
putting these types of assets
under water and so forth.
We wanted to be diligent
and methodical about it.
Let me turn the page here.
The phase that
we're in right now
is we've gone through
the initial exploration,
we've put our submersibles--
our AUVs-- in the water,
and now we've actually
had a whole slew
of papers come out
examining the microbialites
at different stages.
And we have moved
into a phase now where
we're using the deep worker
mapping data and honing in
on different regions of
the lake that we want
to visit and collect samples
from in a similar way that we
did when we first started
exploring the lake where we're
actually sampling down to the
millimeter or sub-millimeter
scale.
But what's cool,
as I mentioned, is
that the physical, as it
says up here, are the mental
and the operational rigors
that are associated with scuba
diving are very, very similar
to operating in space.
This is why NASA actually
puts all of their astronauts
through a lot of rigorous
underwater testing.
And before you can even go
out of the International Space
Station to do a space walk,
you will spend hours-- hundreds
of hours underwater at
the Neutral Buoyancy Lab
at the Johnson Space Center
operating and kind of fixing
or doing whatever it is
you have to do on that EVA
but in this underwater
environment.
So what we have done
previously prior to the phase
that we're in right
now in terms of looking
at remote operations
between a science
team and those
operating under water
and the latency effects
that we talked about
that we have been
simulating is as follows.
So we've had the
submersibles underwater,
and we have a chase
boat on the surface
so we always know where
this submersible is.
And we also have information
passing through a tether that
includes high definition
video, as well
as the voice of the
submersible pilot.
And on board of this chase
boat here, we actually
have what's called an
inter-vehicular CAPCOM.
And so what that person does
is they are meant to mimic,
as I showed you earlier on, the
role of the astronaut sitting
within that pressurized or
free flyer kind of vehicle.
And that person is the
direct connection or voice
to this pilot who's
within the sub itself.
And the IV CAPCOM
role is extremely
important, as it is currently
during regular NASA missions,
is that they have to have
sort of a couple of rules.
They have to be empathetic.
So typically they're
also an astronaut.
They've also been underwater.
But they also have to have the
kind of intellectual knowledge
of the environment that they
can help this person in a very
rapid fire way so that
the science that we need
is retrieved.
The information is then
actually sent by Wi-Fi
back to this 56-foot
trailer that's
sitting on shore
at Pavilion Lake.
And there are a
bunch of scientists.
So we've had 20 to 30 scientists
sitting, examining the data
as it comes back.
But this link here
is actually delayed.
So we've delayed that during the
sub ops by 50 seconds one way.
And that actually sounds
like nothing, but what it did
is created a whole lot
of mess when we initially
started testing
this configuration.
People were stepping
on each other.
You would wait for the
response and you'd say,
did you copy that?
Wait.
Did you copy that?
And then you'd be
responding, and it was just
a complete mess.
So what we ended
up having to do is
institute a lot of different
operational, I guess,
kind of constraints into
how we spoke to each other
during these latencies.
So we would do things like
actually say 30 second morning.
There's going to be a
transmission coming through.
And then the person
in the submersible
would stow their equipment.
They would put
themselves into a hover.
They would put their
muffin to one side.
And then they could wait
for that incoming ding,
and then the
conversation would start.
And once that starts
then you're kind of
locked into a conversation.
And then when it ends, it ends.
But at least there's
no misunderstanding
or miscommunication
in terms of when
something starts and stops.
This is all common sense, and
it sounds a bit ridiculous.
At least we're figuring out.
We're like, well, come on.
But the thing is,
nobody had actually
ever done delayed
communication of this sort
before-- underwater, under
these types of circumstances.
There had been
other tests, but not
under this type of real
scientific return environment
where there were graduate
students sitting back here that
required the data to come back,
required certain information
to come back to them, otherwise,
they wouldn't graduate.
So it's a real
additional pressure
aside from the pressure
of being underwater.
We also figured out during this
first test, which was in 2011,
that the second point here that
I'm going to talk to you about
is that depending on the
operation at hand-- so
whether it was doing sort
of long range mapping
and that communication
between the sub pilot
and the scientists
above on the surface,
or if it was actually going
in to sample something--
we would actually hand
off operational control
between the IV CAPCOM that was
on the surface or those people
that were sitting on shore.
And when there's something
that's much more high tempo,
we really had to
hand off to those
that were all on the lake.
So everything ended
up getting controlled
by this group of
individuals here
who are in real time non-delayed
communication with each other.
Once again, sounds
very common sense,
but nobody had actually done
that experiment in the past.
And so all of this information
has since been carried forward
to all of the NEEMO tests
and other simulations that
have been done at
JSC, and are now
getting incorporated
into the general kind
of operational planning for
deep space missions for humans.
So where we are
right now is we just
got back in June of this year.
We went back to Pavilion Lake,
this time solely operating
with scuba divers and
remotely operated vehicles.
And so what we did
here, as I mentioned,
is we've gone back and
actually identified regions
of the lake that are of
interest to us to sample
at high resolution.
And we have a
couple of questions
that we're now trying to
ask that are still related
to whether or not our
communications protocols,
our operational
protocols, and so forth,
are still relevant when you
go from dealing with people
in these free flyers to now
a situation where it's really
make it or break it when
you have people that
are outside of the submersibles.
When they are diving we
cannot move beyond the, say,
20 minutes that they
have underwater.
That will push the
limits of the dive,
take them into
decompression mode.
It creates a whole lot of
difficulties the same way
that it does if you're
out as an astronaut on EVA
and you only have nine hours.
The fundamental
difference for us
operationally is that in the
sub, if something goes wrong,
you actually can be in there
very happily for six hours.
If you have to,
in emergency mode,
you can be in
there for 72 hours.
As a diver, that's it.
You only have that 20 to 40
minutes, depending on the dive,
and then you really
have to surface
or all hell breaks loose.
So the tempo very
much changed for us,
and the kind of
complexity of what
we were trying to do
actually increased,
despite the fact that we weren't
putting these large scale
assets underwater.
So the set up that we
have-- actually I'm
going to go forward
to this slide
first-- was to test this
operational or this ConOp that
has been designed through
NEEMO and Desert Rat's work
to mimic a trip to an asteroid
or to the moons of Mars.
And so in this case, you
have a science team that's
sitting on the
earth, and there's
a latency or delay
between the science team
and those that are actually
out, let's say, on the asteroid.
And you would have a
couple of people sitting
in this deep space
station here, and they
would be acting as
your IV communication
with the extra vehicular
crew and communication
with the science team.
So they would split duties.
And then you'd actually have
potentially two divers out,
maybe one in a free
flyer, or both on EVA.
And so they wanted us to
test this configuration,
and that's exactly what we did
in that we had, once again,
a chase both with
these two IV people
sitting here on
the boat, and then
two divers underwater
supported by other divers.
And then all of the science
team was actually back onshore
receiving the data.
So what we ended up
doing is actually
going through a variety
of different tests.
I'll show you this video which
shows you the Neutral Buoyancy
Lab that I spoke about
earlier on in order
to prep ourselves to get
to the field the summer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So a lot of work went
into actually designing
the operations, the
communication structure, and so
forth.
And then we took ourselves
to the Neutral Buoyancy Lab,
which is a pool which
is over 60 feet deep.
It has a full-scale mock up
of the International Space
Station within it.
And we use this as a test
bed for our planning.
So this is our science team, and
I'll tell you a bit about them
in a moment.
This is-- pardon me
here-- is a board that
was put in by the NBL
crew at a 45 degree angle
to mimic the lake basin.
And it's actually a series
of old shuttle tiles,
but it worked marvelously
for our purposes.
As you saw in that, there
were six different divers
that we had.
All of them were
trained up to operate
under a couple of
different circumstances.
They were all tethered so that
we could hear their voice.
We could see the video
coming from them.
We have GoPros attached
to them, as well as
some of them have
handheld cameras.
All of that data was then
streamed to our remote science
team, which in this case
was sitting by the pool
but away from the folks that
are operating under water.
And then we instituted a delay
in this very safe environment.
So we did this first before
we moved out into the field.
One of the things that you
saw was some multiple screens
of video that was coming in
from the different divers
from different angles.
One of the research
questions that we
have going in to this
phase of our program
here is which cameras provide
the best view and perspective
depending on which task
that you're interested in?
So if you're interested
in the science,
are you most
interested in the view
that's coming back from
the handheld camera
or from the shoulder cam?
Or if you're interested
in understanding
the lay of the
operations, perhaps it's
the shoulder cam
that's more important.
One of the reasons why
we're asking these questions
and testing for which ones
are the most valid depending
on the task-- and we're
doing that quantitatively--
is because if you ask a
scientist how many cameras
do need on a free flyer when you
go to the moon or an asteroid
to do your science, they will
say as many as you can give me.
How much bandwidth do you need?
As much as you can give me,
which isn't very helpful.
And we've seen this at Desert
Rats where we've mocked up
the science, and
the scientists have
all sorts of cameras of
various degrees of definition,
streaming videos, taking
stills, and what it does
is just shuts down
the whole system.
So we wanted to look at, in
this real science environment,
and provide learning
the ops group, what
are the types of
cameras that you need?
And so this is some
of the work that we've
been doing as well
as integrating
this robot within our lives.
And so there's another
question that we've
been asking, in terms of what is
the role of a robotic assistant
when you're conducting these
types of extravehicular
activities?
A lot of people see a
robot as the best way
to use it as kind of
like a tool caddy,
like it just kind of sits
there and you put stuff on it.
But we've always
felt that that's
sort of under-utilizing
the capability of a robot.
And so we've been using
it as different camera
view as a scout,
as well as a tool
caddy, and other
different mechanisms.
So let me see what
time we have here.
We've got a bit more time.
But what I want to
talk to you about
is what we did this summer.
So as I mentioned, we had ROV
and diver operations together.
And in the back
room, once again,
we had a whole
science team that was
viewing the data coming back.
And also, we were
collecting metrics on
which of the camera point of
views were the most useful
to them and when.
One of the cool things
we had this summer
is the involvement
of Steve Squires.
He is the principle investigator
of the Mars Exploration Rovers
and the head of the
NASA Advisory Council.
And so he's been
running robots on Mars
for a very, very long time.
But if you asked
the dude would you
want to send another robot to
Mars or would you want to go,
he would say, I'll go.
And that was sort of
validated a million times
over when he was there
with us this summer,
because he-- what we
did, and I'm not showing.
That's like three or
four other talks--
is that prior to getting to
this stage when we went in fully
with our divers and our
science team and our robots,
we actually broke things down
into different engineering
runs and operational runs.
And he went out and drove
the ROV around for us
so we could test the COMS
all throughout the lake.
And he said to me, you
know, the first time
he did a dive-- it was just the
checkout dive within Pavilion
Lake-- it was a
total game changer.
Suddenly, he moved
from somebody who
he felt that he had a
very cursory understanding
of the microbialites and
what he was looking at
and what their relationship
with the environment
was, to suddenly, when
he was there, you know,
coming back to your
question earlier on,
he had this real time
intellectual resolution,
which was very rich
and very intimate.
And so he said,
imagine like when
he thinks about that in
terms of extrapolating
that knowledge, that feeling,
to what he's been doing
for the past decade on
Mars, he just feels cheated.
He's like, come on, after 10
years of driving these Rovers,
I could have walked around
and made massive discoveries.
So that's where
we're at right now,
and it's been great to get
his involvement and his point
of view on this whole program.
And so one of the things that we
do in terms of our capabilities
is designed for a mechanism
so that the scientists can
see the data that's
coming in rapidly,
synthesize it, and
make it useful to them
so they can make decisions,
changes in the dive plans,
the traverse plans of the
subs, whatever it may be.
When we first went in with
the submersibles in 2008,
it was really like
caveman style.
Like we had two
subs in there, we
were recording the data on
board of the submersible,
and then all of that
was actually tape.
It had to be brought
up to the surface
and then transferred so
that we could archive it.
And none of us actually
got to see the data
when we were in the field.
And so what ensued was this.
We had a couple of scientists
come up from 200 feet
and say, holy cow, I saw--
well, they swore, but anyways,
they'd say, no, I
saw microbialites
were red at 200 feet.
And the other one was
like, no, you didn't.
They're black.
And then the other said, no,
you guys are totally wrong.
And it was just because
the lights were on.
And this went on, and
it was ridiculous.
It was a completely
ridiculous banal conversation.
And all we had to do was
actually view the tape,
see where we were so we
could either go back to it
or solve the color issue.
So in the subsequent
year we actually went in
with this ground
data system that
was a piece of software
that's designed and aims
and built upon--
you know, predicated
upon Google Earth-- that
allowed us to synthesize
the telemetry so we
knew where we were,
the video, the still
data, and the notes,
which is very important to a
field scientist-- we write,
scribble every last thing
into our field notebook.
Suddenly, that's all here and
all coupled and synthesized
in one repository.
So now we could actually scroll
back in time very rapidly.
The science team could hear
this argument between divers
and say, I just viewed the tape.
It's clearly red and
then it's solved.
And then that
ridiculous conversation
that went on for
two hours is done.
And then you can
say, well, it is red.
That's very interesting.
Please sample that for me and
collect the tips, the middle,
and the subsurface, and
that will be interesting
because it will help
solve my hypotheses.
So XGDS was in its
sort of nascency
when I met the engineers at
Ames and talked with them
about some of our issues.
And they said,
well hey, look, we
have this Rover that we've
been working on-- this robot--
and we've been designing
this ground data
system that basically,
at that time,
kind of synthesized
the telemetry
and some of the other kind
of engineering components
into this software.
And so they said, we really
want a real science question
to work on.
So they started designing
this XGDS system.
I think there's
actually a talk online
by Matt Deans that explains
this in more detail.
But what has happened is
this XGDS program has since
been absorbed by
NEEMO, by Desert Rats,
and now is being used by
something called the Mojave
Volatiles Prospector, which is
a precursor robotic mission we
just did in the Mojave Desert
to a mission that hopefully will
fly in the next five
years to the moon, which
is called Resource Prospector.
And that mission is to go
to the far side of the moon
and look for water.
But it's got a very
short time frame.
It's not like what's
happened on Mars.
It's only going to
operate for 10 to 14 days.
It's got to look for water.
It's going to be
deking in and out
of permanently shadowed regions.
And so operationally the
tempo is much more akin
to what we've been dealing
with at Pavilion Lake.
And this XGDS system
has since sort of
grown into that environment too.
So it's one of the
really great capabilities
that has been designed
at Ames and that we've
had a lot of interesting
development success with.
This summer we had a new
challenge for the engineers.
And that was that they had
to design a system which
was even faster than what
they had designed in terms
of our decision-making
capabilities for the subs.
This is because now, as I
mentioned, we had divers.
And the divers were
only underwater
for 20 to 40 minutes.
We were also-- every
time the divers came up
they had loads of samples.
We had grad students.
This is Mark [? Blenn. ?]
He's actually from Canada.
And they were examining the
microbialites as they came up.
Another scientist
from New Zealand.
And actually looking at
the surface structure,
looking at the microbes
that were there,
and then feeding that
data back into XGDS,
and we had to react to
that as well as we planned
the dives and even within
the dives themselves.
So there was a new kind of
higher level of-- or a faster
pace, really, to
the whole operation.
Every evening we
would have discussions
that went on and on,
and heated discussions
between scientists
and engineers.
And scientists almost
broke out into fistfights,
but were very, very productive.
And we also-- yeah.
I know.
Nobody got killed.
So that's always good.
No paperwork.
So we also went back to,
as I showed you earlier on,
some of these
acceptability assessments.
And we're just compiling
this right now,
and we're hoping to
put a draft together
by the end of this
year for publication,
but what we were
looking at, once again,
is acceptability
ratings in terms
of the simulation
that we conducted,
as well as some of
the capabilities
and how well they were rated
in terms of their success
in supporting our mission.
So some of the things
that we found--
this is kind of
high level learning
at this point in time--
is that it was a very--
we found by consensus that, as
I showed you in that earlier
diagram where we were
looking at the ConOps
where you have two people
as IV supporting the two
other people out on EVA-- there
has been a lot of discussion
as to whether or not you
really need two IVs supporting
or just one.
That makes a huge
difference to NASA
in terms of training, how much
effort you've got to put in,
you've got to pay
two extra people,
and all that sort of thing,
and two extra crew going out
that far.
We found that we could
not have done anything
under that kind of tempo,
that kind of difficulty,
without those two IV.
One focused actually
solely on the science,
talking to the science
team in delay mode,
talking to the other
IV about the science
and making suggestions
to the dive team.
And then the other
IV was completely
focused on their
safety, essentially,
telling them where they
were within the dive
plan, how much time
they had left based
on the pressure that the
divers were reading back
to us as it decreased over time.
And that subdivision was
very, very important to us
and rated as extremely important
throughout the entire program.
We also started to examine
the camera and imagery
capabilities, as I talked to
you about, and look specifically
at the shoulder
cam, the ROV view,
as well as the
handheld camera that
was used by one of the divers.
Now the way that that diver
used that handheld camera is
that he would, as
we found a sample
we wanted or microbialite
we wanted to sample,
he would scooch in very
gently and use the camera
to actually image that structure
in high definition video.
And that was
streaming back to us,
and we were then feeding
forward decisions as to whether
or not to sample
there or move on.
And then there was
the shoulder cam
which gave us a view over
the shoulder as to where
their hands were and what
was going on around them.
And then we had the ROV,
which was giving you
a different point of
view, kind of the lay
of the land, the
contextual shot.
And what we found is that
the camera that was handheld
was most important
to the scientists,
because that allowed us to
say, hey, go in tighter.
Let's see if that little nodule
that's a centimeter in width
is actually red
or if it's green.
That helps us with our tests
or different hypotheses.
But what we did
find which was brand
new to any of these analogs
is that we don't actually
need a scientist's
high definition video.
You can collect that on site.
But all we needed was a
high definition still.
But what that means
is that if you're
going to shoot back
a still of something,
it means a couple of things.
First of all, the
scientists or the diver
that's underwater or the
astronaut that's on EVA
has to have quite a substantial
amount of scientific training
under their belt to know
when to press the button
to send you a still.
Otherwise, he or she could
be just sending you garbage.
And so we had the benefit of
having one of the-- really
what's considered one of
the best cold water divers
in the world who is also an
astrobiologist in that role.
So he knew exactly when
to say this looks good
or this doesn't look good.
But if you didn't
have that and it
was say, somebody that didn't
come from a science background,
that may have been
very different.
So there are nuances
to the things
that we learned that we've
been capturing over time.
These are kind of prompts to
me to talk to you about some
of the other learning.
But one of the
other things that we
did, a lot of the learning
that I just showed you
was done under the 50
second one-way delay.
Something that had never been
done before prior to June
was actually testing in these
circumstances in a five minute
delay mode-- five
minute one way.
This changes the
operation substantially,
because five minute one
way means 10 minute return.
And that doesn't even account
for the kind of thinking time
that the science team
might need to make
a decision on whether
to sample, to move on,
or to come up and so forth.
And so what we did is we
designed this circuit sampling
strategy that essentially
meant that the people on EVA,
the divers underwater, were
never without something to do.
And we joke about the fact
that we should probably
institute this at work as well,
where there's always a task
that you have to be doing so
to be as efficient as possible
in the time you've got.
So these guys only had
20 minutes underwater.
We've got a five minute delay.
You can do the math.
It just makes it a really
difficult situation.
But they had to select samples
that the grad students could
use to graduate, and
they had to do it
but still give us the option.
So what we did is allowed
them to-- we preselected
a circuit based on the ROV
data and deep worker data that
had already been garnered,
and then actually allowed them
to go through and drop,
basically like breadcrumbs--
here's a good one,
and then image it really tight.
And all that information
is coming back
to the science team.
And as they were waiting,
they would kind of
progress along in a bit of
a circuit like a circle.
And then as they were waiting
for us to make our decision
and they were able to
time that underwater too,
they were tasked with
other scientific data
that we wanted to get, such
as water samples or collection
of rocks and so forth.
So we made sure that
every single task
was understood in terms
of the amount of time
it would take, and ensured that
by the time the decision came
back to them, they were ready
and prepped and able to go,
and that every task that
we needed them to get done
was done without them
having to wait around.
What the scientists did
in order to expedite
the decision-making process
under this time delay was this.
They knew that they
were going to have
four or five different options,
and there was a leader board.
So as soon as they
saw the first option
they would sort of take a
guess as to whether or not
it was going to get prioritized
as one or maybe as four.
And they would kind of throw
that up on a leaderboard,
and those numbers
and those projections
were getting sent
forward to the boat
and then communicated
down to the divers.
And that would get updated.
So, for example, if they
saw a, they would say,
well, I think it's
going to number four.
And then if they came
to the next sample, b,
they would say, oh,
nope, a is better than b.
And that leaderboard
kept getting rapidly
updated and that information
communicated down the divers.
And what that did was
it prompted the divers
to already know where they might
be going to do the collections.
Now, I don't know if any of
you are divers in the room.
Actually are any of
you divers in the room?
OK, cool.
So you know diving
is actually not easy.
There's a lot going on.
There's a lot coming at you.
And in this circumstance, they
are fully suited in dry suits,
and they are at four degrees--
they're in four degrees
Celsius weather--
pardon me-- water.
And they're also
wearing full face masks,
which are highly uncomfortable.
Thank you.
And so there is a
lot coming at them.
And so, for them to be
able to prepare themselves
for something is highly
useful in terms of making sure
that they're managing through
everything that they're
dealing with
including their air.
I only have five minutes left,
but some of the other learning
that we came out with is that
actually very clear marking
of any samples is
extremely important.
In the past, what's
been used in other tasks
is just kind of dropping little
weights with string coming off
them without any clear
markings on them.
This is actually not-- we can't
actually do anything with that
if you're dealing
with these five minute
delays and these kind of
leaderboard circumstances.
So these types of
learnings is something
we're putting together in a
paper that, as I mentioned,
will be pushed forward to
the other test environments.
So just some kind of summary
statements about these Pavilion
Lake and other types
of tests like this
is that these non-simulated
science activities,
they act as an honest
forcing function
for us to drive out the
operational, the technical,
and the mission components that
enable an enhance hypothesis
testing, and ultimately
scientific discoveries.
We want to go out
and we want to test
and we want to refine all of
these operational and concepts
and capabilities,
and then test again.
Now some of the
issues we have is
that right now, Pavilion
is really n equals 1.
There's only really that as
it stands in the community,
and we need to
have more of these.
And that's what we're
working on right now.
We have an opportunity
because scientists at NASA
do go out into the field a lot.
And so this summer we're headed
back, and what we're doing
is going to make our
lives more difficult,
but it's still an
interesting task.
We're going to take
some of our science team
and have them sit at home
and see what that does to us.
So we're not exactly sure how to
enable ourselves to communicate
and stay motivated as a
team in this circumstance,
because when you're in the
field and it's very intense,
it changes the dynamic--
the working dynamic.
If you're working on a project
and you're all working together
over long hours it sort
of-- you kind of gel.
So if you have people
sitting far away,
but they still have to be
part of that intensity,
how are we going
to deal with that?
And this distributed science
backroom team scenario
is going to happen when we
have deep space missions.
You can't have
everybody move to,
let's say Houston or whatever.
You're going to have to stay
at home with your families,
but still be really locked
into these high tempo mission.
Another program which
we just starting up
which is called Finesse,
as Chris mentioned earlier,
is actually a
land-based program where
we are using robots
and humans out
in two different environments.
One is in the East
Snake River Plain
in Idaho, which is an old
volcanic field as well
as an impact crater
in northern Quebec,
called the West
Clearwater Impact Crater.
And so we're using
those two environments
as scientific
learning environments
again, and hoping to tack on a
lot of the exploration learning
that we've been doing
up there Pavilion Lake.
So thank you very much to
all of you for coming out
and for those who are
attending the talk virtually.
I really appreciate it.
And I am ready take any
questions you may have.
And the AV worked.
Thanks so much.
Yeah.
How much ex-- OK.
So the question is do I
have any metrics on how much
extra lag decreases the
efficiency of the work?
So like if we
increase the latency,
how does it decrease
the efficiency?
That's a great question.
So we have two years worth
of testing, so n equal 2.
Hooray.
And what we've found is
that actually the science
that we've managed
to return has not
diminished in its productivity
nor in its output.
But there have got to be
nuances in there for sure
that we're not capturing.
But in terms of the
metric that we capture,
which is science return, have
we tested our hypothesis?
Yes.
Have we published a paper?
It's actually one for one.
So there has been no change
between whether we're
using the submersibles, the
divers under 50 second delay,
or if we change it to a
five minute one way delay.
We're still getting the
data return that we need.
But what has
fundamentally changed
are the kind of support
tools that we need
and the camera views.
And once again coming
back to the XGDS system
and how rapidly we're able to
extract the information we want
from that and use
that to make decisions
There has been some
big learning that's
come in that we're trying
to institute this year
to change and update that system
so that it can support these
I guess like higher
tempo kind of scenarios
as well as the
scenarios where you
have these longer
latencies instituted.
Yeah.
No.
That's a great question.
We have not.
We meant to do that this year,
but it got very complicated
very fast.
And so we ended up
focusing just simply
on the different camera angles.
But next year we hope to do.
And we hope to be able
to dial up and down
the different camera views
and actually, do that first.
Going in, I guess, with
a kind of a test platform
where we actually
know at this moment
we're going to be dialing
back this and that,
but then after
that start to react
with what the scientists
are requiring.
So if we see them and their
only-- the science CAPCOM
is saying, actually
at this point,
we only need to view
the hand held camera,
then we'll dial everything else
back and AMP up that bandwidth.
But yeah.
That's a great question.
And once again, that's a
completely outstanding question
for us, because any scientist
will say, give me it all.
Give me all she's got.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
DR. DARLENE LIM: Thank you.
Thanks.